okay would the the your famous Vlad
story
is that going to be in the show hell
yeah but it ain't gonna be no story it's
gonna be the real [__] you know what I'm
saying
the you've seen the like reenactment
cartoons of you that [__] was hard it's
great that should be a real cartoon
series zero percent of that story was
capped that was all actual factual
that's what's going on man but I can't
really speak too much that [__] that
with so many Twisted terms it did
already but I can't even you know say I
said what I said man that's a quiet
that's one of the best you know what I'm
saying like you do possess some of the
best internet moments of all time so
you have like a [__] you're like the
internet moment God it's like you and
Kevin Gates right now
when Kevin Gates said and he puts his
hand in a car battery and it just starts
I was like nah
what are we talking about right now
like what are we doing bruh anyway
um all right so you got the game console
at walmart.com yep walmart.com man y'all
go order y'all one today man the new
album new album Soldier season out right
now tour in August Soldier World Tour in
August September going crazy you have
clothes out Soulja boyapparel.com go
order you some hoodies you know what I'm
saying all my designers out there yeah
Soulja Boy apparel you're wearing no
this ain't Soulja Boy apparel right here
hang on okay so I gotta I got a serious
question to ask you I gotta be honest
with you let me give you some business
advice from a guy who you know I've seen
a lot of people say wear the clothing
line no no no just hip-hop clothing
lines I've seen them all come and go
usually oh yeah usually the ones that
have the rapper's name in the title of
the clothing line fail miserably yeah
think about it Snoop Dogg clothing ate
[__] Outcast clothing what about what
about Sean John
that's that wasn't called Puff Daddy
clothing though Sean John it was called
Sean John it wasn't called Puff Daddy
clothing but he changed that Diddy puffy
P we didn't know what his name was at
the point nobody's wearing that [__] if
it's called did he close
what if they say bootleg Kev podcast is
not it well I'm not putting out [__]
clothes but you put out a podcast and
they got your name in it it's the same
thing I'm gonna be honest it's the same
time
right now I gotta wear my [__] my
[__] name I wouldn't I would never
ask somebody to wear my [__] name on
their [__] but why would you ask them to
listen to your podcast with your name
it's different how because who says it's
different you're not even wearing your
[__] it's sold out
sold out baby are you sure before I got
up here it sold out it's missing oh the
last show I can't I have to take the
hoodies off they were taking the hoodies
off of me I'm about to Google this [__]
right now
I'm gonna review your uh your your
clothes with you right yes
36 year old one man got a podcast named
the bootleg Kev podcast and coming at me
because I got Soulja Boy up here I'm
just trying to help you out I'm trying
to help you up bootleg Kev okay okay I'm
okay okay
let's get our name out there what you
want me to call it Soldier
boyapparel.com I'm on the website use
the cold Soldier for 10 off your order
yes we doing night we them hoodies is
flying right now I can see everyone we
went flying Soldier season
flying they're dripping let me can I do
okay people are buying slides with your
cartoon face on them yes you want to see
the back end I gotta show you the
statistics shout out if they're gonna
buy my album why won't they buy my
clothes
if they gonna follow me why won't they
follow something with my name in it so
like okay this hoodie right it just says
Soulja Boy apparel that's fire it's not
what now you hating I'm not yeah this is
cool it's like a cartoon version of you
but you mean cool that's fire too how
many of this sweater did you sell a lot
of this purple bro I have 11 million
followers on Facebook seven million
followers on this people went Bangladesh
buying this [__] all over the world I
have 11 million followers on Facebook
seven I like the shorts those shorts are
fire fires seven million on Instagram
five million on Twitter you don't think
off of one post I'm not doing how many
sales I'm doing off of one post okay I
got it out Kev people are buying this
shirt right here yes people buy people
buy what go yard
it's the same style it's the same not me
I can't do my not you but people are